الله اكبر
طبتم وطابت اوقاتكم نكمل معكم هذه التغطيه
من الاختلاف والخلاف السياسي في الساحه
السياسيه السودانيه الى الصراع المسلحي
بين المؤسسه العسكريه ذاتها
نبدا معكم هذه التغطيه حيث قال مراسل
العربيه ان اشتباكات تجري بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في مروي
والعاصمه الخرطوم مضيفا انه تم سماع اصوات
اسلحه ثقيله بمحيطه قاعده مروي العسكريه
وان اعمده الدخان تتصاعد من داخل القاعده
واشار مراسل العربيه الى ان تشاري حال من
الهلع والخوف بين السكان في مروي وانهم
يغادرون الاسواق في هذه الاثناء اعلنت
قوات الدعم السريع في بيان لها انها
تفاجات بقوه كبيره من الجيش السوداني تدخل
الى مقر تواجدها في ارض المعسكرات بسوبا
في الخرطوم قبل ان تشن عليها هجوما كاسحا
بكافه انواع الاسلحه الثقيله والخفيفه
ووصفت قوات الدعم السريع ما حدث بالاعتداء
الغاشم مشيره الى ان قيادتها اجرت اتصالات
مع كل من الاليه الرباعيه ومجموعه الوساطه
واطلعتهم على الامر
[موسيقى]
من مروي ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه نزار
بقداوي نزار اهلا بك ما الذي حدث واجمل
لنا الصوره في اخر التطورات لديك الان
اخر التطورات انا اعمده الدخان ما زالت
متصاعده داخل قاعده مروي العملياتيه
الجويه هنا في مدينه مروي شمال السودان
كما تتابعون عبر الصور التي نقلت قبل قليل
حصريا على العربيه
رصدنا ايضا عديد الاصابات داخل صفوف قوات
الجيش السوداني وصلت الى مستشفى مروي
العسكري وهنالك بعض الجنود تم تحويلهم الى
مستشفى كريمه مدينه اخرى هنا في الولايه
الشماليه القوات المسلحه السودانيه ما
زالت تنتشر في عدد من الطرق الرئيسه هنا
داخل مدينه مروي
السماع لدوي واطلاق نار ما زال متواصلا
ومتقطعا داخل قاعده مروي العسكريه الجويه
هذا هو الوضع مدينه مروي الان مدينه مغلقه
بالكامل المواطنون في منازلهم عدا بعض
الشوارع التي فيها
حاره ولمواطنين ولقوات عسكريه سوق المدينه
اغلق بالكامل المحاله التجاريه اغلقت
بالكامل عدا المرافق الحيويه ومن بينها
مستشفى مروي العسكري القومي الان الصوره
تشوبها حاله التوتر وانعدام الامن
البيانات والبيانات المضاده ويقوله الدعم
السريع ما يقوله الجيش السوداني كل هذه
البيانات وكل هذه الاشارات تضع مروي
تواجهه اولى لاحداث ساخنه بدات منذ صباح
هذا اليوم وانتقلت بكلياتها الى العاصمه
السودانيه
نتحدث عن الوضع الميداني وفق المعلومه
تعلم ان الوضع صعب لديك نزار ولكن من خلال
ما تم نقله خلال الساعات القليله الماضيه
وحتى الان باي المحاور يتم تتم الاشتباكات
بين قوات الدعم السريع وبالتالي الجيش
وصلت قبل اربعه ايام تمركزت في الجانب
الشمالي الشرقي لقاعده مرو
ي على الرغم من التوجيهات التي صدرت اليها
بضروره ان تخرج وان تعود ادراجها لكنها ما
زالت في تلك المنطقه قوات الجيش السوداني
كانت على حدود اقل من 200 متر في مقابله
القوات التي وصلت قبل اربعه ايام قوات
الجيش
عبر محورين محور القوات الجويه مرتكزه
بطبيعه الحال لانها قاعده الجويه عسكريه
اضيفت اليها قوات بريه من هنا من مروي من
الفرقه التاسعه عشره مشاه الى جانب قوات
السند ودعم وصلت من منطقه الشماليه
العسكريه وهنا الحديث والتاكيد على مدينتي
عبره وشندي وفيهما قاعدتين او اللواء
للجيش وفرقه للجيش في تلك المدينتين وصلت
وشكل الدعم وسند عندما بدات هذه
الاشتباكات بدات في الجزء الشمالي الشرقي
حيث تتواجد قوات الدعم السريع انتقلت الى
منتصف القاعده والان توزعت ما بين المنتصف
وما بين الشمال وما بين الجنوب القاعده
بالتالي اتسعت الاشتباكات واتسع اطلاق
النار عبر المدفعيه وعبر الاليات الثقيله
لتصبح
كل اعمده الدخان متصاعده من مختلف
النقاط القاعده التي تقدر مساحتها بنحو 18
كيلومتر مربع نزال شده هذه الاشتباكات هل
هي واحده على كل المحاور ام ان بعض هذه
المحاور او بعض هذه الجهات يتم فيها ربما
قصف بالاسلحه الثقيله بين الطرفين الصوره
غير الط
بيعه هذه الحالات انها تتمركز في في وجود
القوات التي
تبدا اطلاق النار او من مصدر النار يتم
توجيه المدفعيه نحو مصدر اطلاق النار عليه
فان الاشتباكات تاتي من مصدر ويتم الرد
عليها من المصدر الاخر بدات في جزء شمالي
انتقلت الى الوسط انتقلت الى جنوب القاعده
العسكريه وبالتالي تم شمل كل هذه القاعده
باطلاق النار وتوزعت اعمده الدخان فان
الوضع الان الوضع مرتبط داخل هذه القاعده
المعلومات تؤكد بان هنالك جرحى عدد
الخسائر حتى اللحظه غير معلوم تبعيه
القاعده الان لمن غير معلوم كل هذه بيانات
متضاربه ليس هنالك تاكيد قطعي ومؤكد بان
القاعده الان في يد من هل الدعم السريع ام
للجيش السوداني التضارب ليس فقط في مروي
ولكنه ايضا حتى في الخرطوم في السيطره على
القصر الرئاسي من يسيطر عليه بعد ان قالت
قوات الدعم السريع انها تسيطر عليها الجيش
يقول بانها لا تسيطر على القصر الرئاسي
ومقر البرهان اعود ايضا الى مروي مره اخرى
نزار ماذا عن السكان خارج هذه القاعده
بالقرب من هذه القاعده كيف هو الوضع
السكان سيطرت عليهم حاله الذعر والخوف
والرعب الان مروي مطوقه بالكامل بحاله من
الخوف والرعب والترقب يترقبون مالات هذه
العمليه العسكريه التي تم صباح هذا اليوم
وهذه الاشتباكات كل المواطنين الذين
شاهدتهم انتقلوا من منازلهم التي كانت
تجاور تحديدا القاعده العسكريه الى وسط
المدينه من هو يسكن في وسط المدينه انتقل
الى الجانب الغربي من المدينه حيث نهر
النيل وهنالك بعض المواطنين بداوا في عبور
الجسر الذي يربط بين مدينتي مروي ومدينه
كريمه الكره الان يتخوف بعد ان انتشرت هذه
الاشتباكات
واطلاق القذائف وحتى اصابات المواطنين
هنالك عدد من الاصابات في صفوف المواطنين
بعض الذخيره وبعض الروائش التي تطلق من
الذخيره الحيه وصلت واصابت عديد المواطنين
الى جانب ايضا الاصابات التي
وصلت الى صفوف قوات الجيش السوداني
بالتالي الان المواطن يترقب المواطن ينتظر
ويراقب ما الذي يمكن ان يحدث خلال ساعات
المقبله هل ستنجلي هذه الازمه ان تتصاعد
مع اقتراب ساعات الليل هنا في مدينه ملوي
هل يتم الحديث حيث انت عن ربما دعم او
وصول قوات اخرى سواء للجيش او حتى للدعم
السريع هل يتم الحديث عن ذلك وصول امداد
في مثل هذه الحالات تترك هذه الامور
لتقديرات القياده العسكريه هنا في الفرقه
التاسعه عشر مشاه هي تتابع عبر
الاستخبارات العسكريه وعبر مرافضها
المختلفه طبيعه الذي حدث في منطقه مروي
العسكريه هل يستدعي تدخل هل يستدعي سند
ومدد من مدينتي وعبر من الجهه الشماليه في
مدينه طنبله كل هذه التقديرات امنيه
وتقديرات استخباراتيه الجيش السوداني على
علم كيفيه اداره هذه الامور كذلك ربما
تكون هنالك بعض الاشارات حول دعم قد يصل
الى الدعم السريع
هذا مربوط فقط بطبيعه ما سيحدث خلال
الدقائق والساعات المقبله هل ستستمر هذه
الاشتباكات ام ستصل الى نقطه مفصليه
وتتوقف بعدها هذا الاشتباكات ويكون هنالك
حديث سياسي عن وقف هذا اطلاق النار او اي
صلح او اي ترتيبات توقف هذه الاشتباكات
التي بدات منذ صباح هذا اليوم نزار قبل كل
شيء ارجو ان تكون دائما
بسلامه وفي مكان امن سنعود اليك ونعطيك
الان المجال ربما تلمس المزيد من الاخبار
عن الوضع
الضبابيه او المشهد الضبابيه الذي لديك
الان هناك في مروي شكرا جزيلا لمراسل
العربيه نزار بقداوي حتى الان
ايضا معنا من الخرطوم رئيس تحرير صحيفه
الجريده اشرف عبد العزيز سيد اشرف هذا ما
كان يحدث قبل قليل في مروي ولا ايضا في
الخرطوم الوضع ايضا ليس واضحا بيانات
وبيانات مضاده
تكذيب لبعضها ما الذي يحدث كنا في حاله
تفاؤل يوم امس المشهد تعقد صباح اليوم وصل
الى لغه السلاح
معارك دائما ما تعلو يعني اصوات الاخبار
التي تصب في اطار الحرب النفسيه الكل يريد
ان يرفع معنويات قوته ويقول انه يسيطر على
الامور تماما وانه متقدم في المعرفه
العسكريه الميدانيه
ومستقبل هذا السودان وبالتاكيد استمرار
هذه المعركه يعني استمرار انهيار هذا
الوطن ولابد من ان تتصدى الجميع وكل
السودانيين يقفون وقفه واحده وقويه لوقف
هذا الذي يحدث الذي يحدث يمكن ان يمحو
خارطه السودان من الوجود والتقه
باي طرف من الاطراف لانه قادر على حسب
المعركه ربما قد لا تكون هي تكهنات صحيحه
لان هذه المعركه استمرت ستنشف عنها
تداعيات لحرب الاهليه دروس لم تتوقف في
يوم او يومين او شهر او شهرين او سنه او
سنتين فستمر هذه المعركه هذه ما الذي عقد
المشهد يعني خليني افهم بانه كنا ربما كان
هناك تطمينات من ان لا حرب اهليه في
السودان ربما هذه الامور ستتحلحل لكن ما
الذي عقد المشهد واثاره وقلب المشهد راسا
على عقب
الاولى ربما يستطيع كسري شافه الثاني
وقوتي وبالتالي يستطيع التحكم في اداره
الامور ولكن واضح جدا تماما ان هذه القضيه
هي خاطئه حدثت في كثير من الحروب يعني من
قبل في السودان عندما اجتمع البشير بانه
يستطيع ان يحشم حرف في يوم او يومين وصرح
علنا وقال لا اريد اسيرا ولا جريحا ولكن
استمرت المعرفه اكثر من 20 عاما حتى الان
وكذلك ايضا سمير الازرق وفي جنوب كورتوفان
التوقعات دائما بحسب مثل هذه المعارك
بسرعه من كل الاطراف هي من شانها ما يؤجد
ويجعل الاذن ساقيه لسماع مثل هذا النوع من
التحريض فبالتالي ما حدث هو نتيجه ذلك
كانت تحشيش مستمرا بشكل اساسي والخلافات
كانت متصاعده كل يوم وكذلك من يعملون على
التحريض كانوا يسرون على اشعال الفتنه
ويبدو ان هناك اذن ساقيه وجدوها هي جعلت
هذه الفتنه تتحرك بهذه الوتيره التي على
ماذا يعتمد على ماذا يعتمد سيد اشرف على
ماذا يعتمد الدعم السريع في هذه يعني ربما
اذا ما اعتبره البعض التمردا عسكريا البعض
الاخر يعتبره انقلاب على كل الاتفاقات
السابقه هل هل الجيش السوداني يستطيع
السيطره على
على الساحه الان في الخرطوم على الاقل
المعركه لا تستطيع ان تتنبا بمن الذي
سيسيطر بشكل كامل لانها كما اسلفت لك ليست
معركه يوم او يومين وانما هي معركه ستطور
سيطول امندها وسيتضرر منها الشعب السوداني
ولن يكون هنالك منتصرا لان هذه المعركه
ستمح السودان من الوجود وستمزق اوصالها
حتى في اوساط مجتمعاته في خطاب الكراهيه
اصبح منتشرا لحد كبير وهذا يمكن ان يؤثر
على وجود السودان ووحدتها هذه الازمه
الحقيقيه التي ينبغي ان ننظر اليها من
الجانب الاخر اما مساله القتال العسكري
فهي يمكن ان تحقق
انتصارات لن تحل هذه الادويه التي تحمقت
وتجذرت في اوصال المجتمع وكان ممكنا حلها
اذا تم التوقيع على هذه الاتفاقيه وهذه
العمليه السياسيه
اغلاها باعتبار انها هي كانت الوحيده التي
تستطيع
هذا الخبر العاجل لطائرات كانت تحلق في
سماء الخرطوم وهذا وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
يقول الوضع في الخرطوم مقلق
[موسيقى]
وهو يعلق على الوضع في السودان لا نعلم
اذا كان ربما هناك المزيد طيب الان هذا هو
الوضع الميداني هل من انباء من يسيطر على
مقر الرئاسه
في تضارب البيانات
الجيش الافعى ذلك وقال النبوات الدعم
تسيطر على ذلك وانا كما عشقتك في البدايه
انه البدل المتعلقه بمثل هذه الاخبار
تحتاج الى تاكيدات رسميه واساسيه حتى يتم
تصديقها بشكل كامل ولكن
ننتظر في وصول مزيد من التاكيدات من غير
القوات الدعم السريع ومزيد من تاكيدات
التي من الجيش حتى نتاكد من هو الذي يكون
صادق في هذه المعركه الذي تكون فيها
الاخبار نفسها هي جزء من المعرفه نفسها
طيب ماذا عن الخرطوم اين يعني في مروي
عرفنا ربما الجهات او حتى المحاور التي
يتم فيها القتال لكن ماذا عن الخرطوم
اليوم نحن نتحدث عن الجسر
جسر النيل كما يقال لي وكذلك القصر
الرئاسي فقط ام ان هناك ربما ساحات اخرى
مرشحه للاشتباكات بين الطرف
في اغلب اغلب اغلب مناطق
الخرطوم على الاسواق المدفعيه الثقيله
وكذلك الاسلحه الرشاشات الخفيفه كلها
[موسيقى]
تسمع مدينها الثلاث في الخرطوم درمان وفي
بحر ايضا كل ذلك وفي الشرق النيل كل ذلك
يشير الى ان المعركه هي في اتجاه اي الكل
يريد ان يسيطر على مواقع
او يريد ان يخل الاخر من منطقه استراتيجيه
سيطر عليها في اطار
افراد السيطره الكامله وهذا لا يعني ان
المعركه ربما تتوقف في جنوب الخرطوم فقط
اذا لم يتوصل العملاء الى وساطه من شانها
ان تفضي الى وقت اطلاق النار حتى الان
لحين انه ارسلوا بيانا مطمنا
عن ان هنالك
امر تتوقف هذه المسائل وان الامور قد تعود
الى نصابها يتم ايجاد معالجه كامله لها
هذا بحسب بيان صدر قبل قليل من قبل
الوساطه التي تتوسط في هذا الامر بقياده
من يركب الناي واخرين لكن في تق
ديري
يعني في في اوارها وان الحرب تكون مستعرض
بشده معظم المناطق لسه في الخرطوم واحده
في الولايات اخرى من السودان طيب يعني هذه
الصور التي سنعرضها الان هي عباره عن
قذيفه اصابت احد المباني في الخرطوم لا
نعلم حقيقه في اي منطقه ولكن هي نتيجه
للاشتباكات بين الطرفين بين الجيش
السوداني وكذلك قوات الدعم السريع كما
اشار ضيفي واشار مراسلنا يتم احيانا
في منطقه السجانه في الخرطوم كما يقال لي
هذه هي اللحظات قبيل
سقوط هذه القذيفه على المبنى الواقع في
الخلف
واحد المباني في منطقه السجانه كما اشار
مراسلنا في مروي كان هناك اشتباكات
بالاسلحه الخفيفه والاسلحه الثقيله ايضا
في الخرطوم يحدث نفس نفس المشهد اشتباكات
بين الطرفين باسلحه ثقيله وخفيفه في بعض
المحاور السيد اشرف
اليوم الدور الوسيط الذي كان كان لربما
ايضا الجيش السوداني يعلن التنفيذ ضربات
جويه على قوات الدعم السريع قبل ذلك كان
في خبرا عاجل يقول بانه سيطر على المطارات
والقواعد العسكريه ربما نعود بعد قليل الى
قاعده مروي
لنتاكد من مراسلنا هناك سيد اشرف هل
قوه الجويه اليوم بالنسبه للجيش السوداني
تعطيه الافضليه على قوات الدعم السريع هل
نستطيع ان نقول لربما فرض سيطرته ام الى
الان امد المعركه بين الطرفين سيطول
[موسيقى]
لان هذه المعركه هي في وسط الدروع البشريه
الا اذا تمت اباده كثير من المواطنين
وبالتالي يمكن ان
الدعم السريع مثلا نقيب للجيش او كذلك من
قبل الجيش على الدعم السريع لابد او من
قبل الدعم الشريعه للجيش لابد من التاكيد
على ان هو المتضرر الاول والاخير اذا
المعركه لن تهتم في يوم او يومين او سنه
او سنتين لاني كما ذكرت لك النازل المحركه
من هذه القوات وستصل الى مرحله ان تكون
معركه بين المجتمعات السكانيه نفسها لان
هنالك انقساما وخطاب كراهيه فلا بد من حل
هذه الازمه بتدخل سريع جدا من قبل الوسط
وكان الاقليمين من يمكن ان يشكل وسيطا
يعني خاصه اليوم
ربما المشهد السوداني معقد الدعم السريع
له حلفاء في بين القوى السياسيه
وبعض من كان ايضا في القوه المسلحه واليوم
ايضا حتى الجيش لديه هؤلاء الحلفاء الى من
ستتجه البوصله في القوى السياسيه الى اي
الطرفين
هذا هذا هذه امنيات ولكن الواقع
الثوره
السودانيه بالقضيه السودانيه الحاليه
والازمه المعقده القوه الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي الذي تعتبر هي قوه اساسيه
ومؤثره هي اختارت الحل السلمي لانهاء
الحاله الانقلابيه الحاليه في المقابل هنا
تنشط في اطار ان تحسن هذه المعركه من خلال
المواجهه وترفع العهد ثلاثه لا تفاوض ولا
مساومه مع القوات المسلحه باعتبار انها
سيطره على هذه الوضع وترفع رايه حل عضوات
الدعم السريع وما الى ذلك اذا هنالك
يتعلق بهذه القوه هذه القوه السياسيه
لكنها جميعا
ضروره سياسيه لهذه الازمه الكل ينطلق
منطلق مختلف ولكن هو منطلق السلميه ولا
للحرب الذي لم يكن هنالك اصلا
اي طرف من الاطراف فيما يتعلق بقيام الحرب
وانما قد تكون هنالك مواقف سياسيه مشتركه
بين هذه الاطراف فيما يتعلق بالموقف من
اتفاقيه الماء مثلا الاتفاق مثلا فبالتالي
يجب ان لا تسجل السياسيه باي حاجه فيها ما
زالت مؤهله في قياده التوسط بين هذه
المجموعات باعتبار ان
ها في الحياه والاتفاق الاطار عندما تم
توقيعه وقع عليه البرهان وقع عليه
وبالتالي مهما كانت المواقف متقارب بين
هذا لا يعني ان القوس ياتيها الان
لصالح جهه محدده او حليفه لهذا
طيب ساعود اليك سيد اشرف عبد العزيز رئيس
تحرير صحيفه الجريده شكرا جزيلا حتى الان
ارجو ان تبقى معي ساذهب الى ضيفي الاخر
رئيس تحرير صحيفه التيار عثمان مرغني سيد
عثمان اهلا بك يعني رصاصه ربما
في مرويه وسمع صداها في الخرطوم الى اين
ضيفي قبل قليل يقول لربما هذه الشراره قد
تمتد الى بقيه الولايات السودانيه اذا ما
طال امد هذه المواجهات
نعم يعني من المؤسف جدا ان يحدث مثل هذا
في رمضان وبين ابناء الوطن الواحد هؤلاء
طيب سيد عثمان
طيب سنعود اليك سيد عثمان ريثما ريثما
تجهز
اعود الى اشرف عبد العزيز مره اخرى سيد
اشرف يعني
علامه الاختلاف بين الطرفين ما هي النقطه
الفاصله التي ربما جعلت الفراق بين الجيش
السوداني والمؤسسه العسكريه وكذلك الدعم
السريع قبل ذلك هذه اللقطات
لبعض الاشتباكات للجيش السوداني
يطلق قذائف باتجاه مواقع الدعم السريع كما
نشاهد هناك ايضا
هذه القذائف نشاهدها
كما يقول رد لا نعلم
في اي المناطق ايضا
اين كانت هذه القذائف تطلق
لكن قبل قليل شاهدنا صوره فيديو لاحد
احداث تلك القذائف تاريخ تسقط على اصابه
مبنى في الحكومه بحي السجانه كما قلنا لا
نعلم من اطلق هذا هذه القذيفه نحو المبنى
هي اشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله بين الطرفين
في وسط ايضا ضبابيه مشهد من بيانات
وبيانات مضاده من الطرفين السيطره على
القصر
الرئاسي وكذلك على ايضا الجيش رد بان لا
صحه لما ذكره ذكرته قوات الدعم السريع من
سيطرتها على القصر الرئاسي ايضا يقول
الجيش بانه سيطر على اغلب
القواعد العسكريه طيب نعود الى السيد
عثمان المرغني رئيس تحرير صحيفه التيار
السيد عثمان كنت قد سالتك
هذه الشراره التي اندلعت في الخرطوم ومروي
اذا ما استمرت هذه المواجهات
كيف ستصل الى بقيه الولايات والمحافظات في
السودان
نعم المهمه نعلم انه مقر القوتين الجيش
السوداني القوات الدعم السريع موزعه في كل
انحاء السودان يعني ليس هناك مدينه بعض
القرى وحتى بعض المناطق النائيه في
الاطراف في الصحراء تتوفر فيها قوات الدعم
السريع وقوات الجيش السوداني
بتشكيلات مختلفه واذا هذه الحرب بالضروره
ستنتقل الى الاطراف الى المناطق التي
يتواجد فيها الكلى الفريقين وذلك سيجعل
البندقيه لكن حتى الان الحسن الحظي محصور
في مناطق السيطره والقياده في الخصوم
المروي باعتبار انها قاعده استراتيجيه
مهمه
تتمدد الى مواقف اخرى
واذا استطاع العقلاء فعلا محافظه النيران
في هذا الوضع ربما يمكن ان يكون هناك ثاني
او فرصه واسعه للوصول الى التسويه سريعه
لكن اذا امتدت طبعا الى تكون هذا الوضع
والس الفيديو الاكثر رعب لانه سيهدد وحده
التزام كثير من اقاليم السودان اصلا
تفلتات امنيه بصوره واسعه وليس فيها
استقرار امني وهذا يشكل نوع من مساعده تلك
لمزيد من التفاقم خاصه منطقه التي تعاني
من اشتباكات اهليه بين المواطنين وبتعاني
من غياب الامن فاذا وصلت هذه النيران من
هنا من العاصمه الى دارفور فستكون كارثه
الكبرى لان ذلك يجعل كل دافور خارج
السيطره اليوم ما حدث حتى الان هل هي ضربه
خاطفه كسب مواقع استراتيجيه ام هز عصا
لتنفيذ بعض او ربما اعطاء بعض ما كان
يطالب به احد الاطراف يعني اليوم الدعم
السريع والجيش مل خلاف بينهما
على ماذا
واضح تماما الان هو الاستهداف للسيطره
والقياده للمناطق الاستراتيجيه في الخرطوم
التي يمكن ان تحرك الاحداث التي يمكن
تسيطر على قيمه القوات في جميع انحاء
السودان وهذه طبعا ضروره بالضروره دائما
الحرب تحاول ان تصل الى مناطق السيطره او
وفي تقديري هذه المساله ليس فيها
هنا في السودان لان هذه المناطق مناطق
السيطره
الجيشين متقاربه جدا في المناطق واحد
عمليات تدور في
المربع داخل وسط الخرطوم وهذا مما يجعل
المساله تعقيدا للتداخل الشديد بين
الطرفين والقضيه كما فعلا كما تفضلت هي
رغم انها الان وصلت الى
حرب بين الطرفين لكنها نشات خلال الاشهر
الماضيه متراكمه على ظلال الاخت لاف بين
القوتين
الجيش السوداني قياده كل منهما والدعم على
قضايا سياسيه تتعلق بالعمليه السياسيه
التي يؤيدها قياده الدعم السريع واما
تتحفظ عليها قياده الجيش التي ترى انه
لابد من توسيع قاعده المشاركه في العمليه
السياسيه انا محور اختلاف لكنه في النهايه
وجد له من المبرر حول دمج قوات الدعم
السريع لجيش السوداني واصبح مظهر الاعلامي
الذي يحاول ان يظهر هذه القضيه كانها هي
قضيه الاف على قضايا عسكريه بينما الاصل
هو خلاف على قضايا
فيها
طيب سيد عثمان هذه صور لتحليق الطيران
الحربي في سماء الخرطوم قبل قليل قال
الجيش السوداني بان القوات الجويه تنفذ
ضربات تجاه الدعم السريع
ما يشكل ردعا لها اذا هذه الصور صور
لتحليق الطيران الحربي في سماء الخرطوم
ايضا الاشتباكات كما اشار ضيفي تقع في
ربما خطوط تماس متقاربه جدا بين الطرفين
وكما
قال مراسلنا قبل قليل بالاسلحه الثقيله
والخفيفه سواء كانت في الخرطوم او حتى
هناك في مروي كان هناك اشتباكات بين
الطرفين لا نعلم الى اي مدى قد تستمر هذه
الاشتباكات كذلك
المعلومات الوارده هي متضاربه من الطرفين
من سيطره الطرفين قوات الدعم السريع تقول
انها
سيطرت على القصر الرئاسي ومقر اقامه
البرهان بينما قال الجيش بعد ذلك من ان لا
صحه
لهذه الادعاءات الكاذبه كما وصفها ايضا في
مروي يقول الجيش بانه سيطر على
قواعد والمطارات في الخرطوم في السودان
لكن قوات الدعم السريع تقول انها تسيطر
على تلك القاعده اعود الى ضيفيه السيد
عثمان مرغني رئيس تحرير صحيفه التيار سيد
عثمان يعني اليوم حينما نتحدث عن ان كل
الامور وان كان هناك اختلافات منذ امد
بعيد بين بين
الدعم السريع والجيش لكن كل تلك
الاختلافات كانت في مصلحه المؤسسه
العسكريه بمقابل التيارات السياسيه لكن
اليوم هذا الاندلاع في اندلاع الصراع في
داخل المؤسسه العسكريه الى ماذا سيقود
السودان
طبعا يعني الحرب الان بين الطرفين ليس
فيها منتصر على الاطلاق
هذا خبر عاجل اسمح لي الجيش السوداني يقول
بان افراد من قوه الدعم السريع يفرون من
مقارهم تاركين معداتهم قبل قليل ايضا كنا
نقول من ان الجيش السوداني استخدم الطيران
الحربي وتحليقه في سماء الخرطوم تفضل
السيد عثمان
نعم يعني كما ذكرت لك اولا الحرب ليست
فيها منتصر يعني كلا الطرفين الى دماء
سودانيه وهي قوات سودانيه
الخسائر في النهايه محسوبه على الشعب
السوداني وكلما يمكن ان ينتج من هذه الحرب
هو مزيد من اوضاع سيئه للسودان لان
السودان الان يعاني من غياب حكومه مركزيه
منذ اكثر من عام ونصف ويعاني من اوضاع
اقتصاديه متدهوره اثرت على مواطن بصوره
كبيره جدا كلما ستنته ينتج من الحرب وهو
مزيد من اغراق السودان في هذه الازمات
ويتحمل المواطن هذا الوضع المرعب الذي
تحول من مجرد ازمه اقتصاديه الان للمواطن
العادي الى ازمه امنيه تضربه في عز
استقراره ربما الاستقرار الاسري بالضروره
النتيجه في النهايه مهما كانت يعني لن
تكون نتيجه لصالح المجتمع المدني السوداني
السياسي بمعنى صالح القضيه السياسيه لانها
اذا استطاع اي طرف من الاطراف ان يفرط
سلطته فهي في النهايه يعني هي سلطه بندقيه
لن تكون لصالح
المؤسسه السياسيه المدنيه والذي ياتي
بسلطه البندقيه لن يجد متسعا من العقل
والرشد للتفاهم مع اي قوه مدنيه طالما انه
حقق السيطره عن طريق البندقيه فذلك يعني
ان الشرعيه هي الشرعيه القوه وشرعيه القوه
من صعوبه في مكان توجد مساحه او مسافه وسط
للتنازل او الوصول الى حكومه مدنيه ولذلك
سيدفع المجتمع المدني السوداني الثمن
غاليا لانه كان
قالوا ادنى من تفسير
الحكومه
الفتره الانتقاليه ولو صدقت النوايا وجد
العزم كانوا افترض ان تكون هذه الحكومه من
بدايه العام هذا العام 2023 لكن للاسف
البطء الشديد في العمليه السياسيه
والتحايل احيانا عليها ومحاوله استقطاب
المؤيدين من الطرفين المدنيين والاخرين
تنتقل مثلا الى مواجهه عسكريه لن تكون باي
حال من الاحوال لصالح اي طرف مدني
هل يستطيع اي من الاطراف حسم هذه المواجهه
قبل الاجابه سؤال خلينا نقول الاماني
نتمنى ان لا يحصل حسم يعني ان يتم التسويه
ان يتم سماح يعني بدل الحسم السمح ان تتسع
صدور لان الحسم يعني ان الطرف انتصر على
الطرف الاخر بندقيه وهذا امر يعني لن يكون
فيه عدو خارجي لكن هذا الامر وارد قد لا
نتمناه هي ليست امنيات ولكننا نتحدث عن
واقعا ربما يحدث لا سمح الله
نعم يعني في كل الاحوال يعني طبعا القوات
الجيش السوداني هي قوات نظميه
وتحظى بشرعيه دوليه يعني هذا هذا يعني يجب
ان في الاختبار يعني هذا ايضا البيان
البيان الجيش السوداني يصف قوات الدعم
السريع بالعدو هل هو تمرد عسكري سيد عثمان
يعني ما حدث
القوات الجيش السوداني يعني هي ادرى
بتوصيف المساله باعتبار
الطرفان يمثلان
يفترض انهما جيش واحد اذا حدث نوع من
الخلاف بين الطرفين حتى ولو كانوا حتى لو
كانت هذه القوات لا تتبع للدعم السريع لكن
لا تتبع للجيش السوداني وحدث بينهما
خلافات فهي في النهايه طرف منهم تعتبر
الطرف الاخر متمرد على الشرعيه بغض النظر
عن انتمائه او ولايه او تبعيته الى اي
معكر باعتبار ان التكوين العسكري عاده في
المؤسسات العسكريه هو تكوين منضبط
بالتراتبيه معينه ولا يسمح باي جزء من
المؤسسه ان يمارس اي اعمال خارج سياق
السيطره واداره الطرف الاخر هذا الشان هي
قد تعتبر ان هذا تمرد رغم ان قوات الدعم
السريع يفترض انها جزء من الجيش السوداني
فيصبح بعد ذلك حتى هذه العبارات في مثل
هذا التوقيت هي قد تسير مزيد
المزيد من
اللهب مزيد من اثاره الغبن عند الاطراف
كلها وتجعل هناك نوع من محاوله ايجاد
توسيع الحظ اعلاميا انا اعتقد الان
المطلوب صحيح ان القوات المسلحه في ظل
الحروب لا تستطيع ان تقدم اي خطاب تصالحي
لانها تعتبر ذلك يؤثر على معنويات الجنود
لكن القوه السياسيه هذا دورها يجب ان تطلق
بعض الخطاب التصالحي الذي يمكن ان يجبر
الضرر بسرعه سريعه ارجو ان تبقى معي ايضا
الجيش السوداني يقول قواتنا تتصدى للعدو
الذي يدفع بقواته من قواعده المنتشره في
الخرطوم ايضا من هناك من الخرطوم ينضم
اليه اللواء الدكتور امين اسماعيل مجذوب
الخبير الامني والاستراتيجي بمركز
الدراسات الدوليه طيب الدكتور اهلا بك
يعني ليبدا معك اولا من الوضع الميداني
كيف تراه
اولا يبدو انه هنالك خلط في الارقام انا
الفريق الدكتور جلال وليس امين اسماعيل
دكتور
جلال جابر الفريق الدكتور جلال شاكوش حياك
الله هذا ما وصلني اعتذر منك تفضل
عيد السؤال هل كيف ترى الوضع اليوم في
الخرطوم دكتور
الوضع
سيء
يعني ما انتشار الانباء عن معارض ممكله في
مناطق اخرى سواء في مرض
ى ترد ان
باء لكن المعرفه الان دكتور يعني ما
نشاهده الان اذا سمحت لي طيران السوداني
العسكري يحلق في سماء الخرطوم هذه صور
اخرى غير التي عرضناها قبل قليل استخدام
الجيش
لمصطلح عدو الان وصف للدعم السريع ماذا
يعني
اصلا يعني وسط
اللعبه السريع لانه قوه متمرده نعم قوه
نظاميه لكن اصبحت غير منصه للتعليمات
والمرهان العشار لهذه النقطه فطوره مع
سلاح المدرعات انه نحن فقدنا السيطره على
دعم السريع واصبحوا لا ينصحوا او لا
يستجيبوا لاي تعليمات وبالتالي ساقوم
بنهايه التعامل يعني خطوات تلقائيه في
التعامل مع من يوصل لانه متمرد حتى لو كان
هو داخل القوه حتى وحده
سيتم التعامل مع هذه الطريقه عموما نحن
الان لا نعلم من الذي بدا القتال صباح
اليوم
[موسيقى]
اليوم بدا القتال ومنتشر في كل الاتجاه
ات لكن هنالك بيانات مختلفه بيانات متعدده
من الدعم السريع ثم صدر بيانات من القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه الان يعني تشير الى
ان الوضع تحت السيطره تماما وان الم
كبر تاخر كان بالضروره ان يحسموا هذه
التفلتات او هذه عدم الانصياع من يستطيع
حسب الوضع الميداني دكتور
يعني هل الطيران هو هو الحد الفاصل بينها
وربما
بامتلاكه
وقادر الاخ وهو
ولكن خطوط التماس بين الطرفين قريبه جدا
لا لا
موجودين مع بعض في جميع الاماكن في جميع
المناطق في السودان هم في خندق واحد وفي
مكان واحد المساله الان
تقريبا الجاذبيه ثم النظر في كيف صارت
الامور الى هذا المنحرف طيب يعني
حد الفاصل بين الطرفين او ما الذي كان
سببا في اندلاع هذه المعارك لماذا وصلنا
الى هذه النقطه خاصه ان كان هناك وساطات
كان هناك تطمينات من ان الوضع يسير
ربما الى حلحله بين الطرفين والا حرب
اهليه في السودان طبعا هو هذا السؤال هو
المهم جدا والذي يطرحه اي مراقب الان في
من الذي بدا الشيار وفي من الذي بدا
العراق
اللعبه الشريعه افضل البيان قال اعتدوا
عليه في مكانه حوالين الساعه الخامسه
صباحا القوات المسلحه ضرب بيان بواسطه
الناطق الرسمي انه الدعم السريع اعتدى على
كثير من مواقعنا بكثير من الجوازات وهذه
المعركه
خوضها ولابد كان لحسم هذا التمرد يعني
الحقيقه الان غير واضحه فيما يلي هذه
المساله لكن الحقيقه المؤثره للعيال
المستمر بين الجانبين وكل الاسلحه مستخدمه
والتوتر على اشده والمواطن طيب هذه الصور
التي نشاهدها هي صور لمطار الخرطوم وكان
قوه الدعم السريع تعلن سيطرتها على
المطار مطار الخرطوم هذه الصور نشاهدها من
هناك صور الوارده الينا طيب يعني الدكتور
هل اليوم الدعم السريع لديه فقط هذه
الورقه وهي ورقه المواجهه مع الجيش في
الخرطوم او مروي ام لديه اوراق استراتيجيه
اخرى يستطيع تحريكها وبالتالي قد لا نصل
الى حل بين الطرفين ويستطيع الضغط بها على
الجيش
للجلوس الى طاوله
بالضبط تقصد اوراق قتاليه ام اوراق سياسيه
نتحدث عن اشق القتالي
سريع تمدد اصبح
القوات المسلحه تدرب في مراكز القوات
المسلحه تسلح بين سلاح القوات المسلحه
والميزانيه الدوله
عمر حسن البشير ولم يدمج الان ظهرت مشكله
هي التي عملت هذه التاثير قوته لا يساهم
بها يعني لا تعتبر قوه صغيره او هي كتيبه
او هي قوه كبيره هو منتشره في مناطق
متعدده من السودان
بالتالي كانت فكره الدردشه سلميا من خلال
ورشه
التطوير الامني
الدرجه الدعم السريع في القوات المسلحه
يعني وسيله سهله وهادئه وبكل الاحترام
تدمج هذه القوات لانه اصلا هي جزء من هذه
القوات ولا تختلف عنها في شيء رغم ان
لديها قانون خاص بها وقانون منفصل الان
هذه الصوره التعامل مع القتالي مع اذا تم
يعني اذا استمر بهذه الوتيره مؤقت سيكون
له تكلفه ضايجه وله زمن ويستغرق وتكلفه
ماليه ويعني الدوله في دوام من حاله
الفوضى والتشرجم هذه عن الاوراق العسكريه
السفاره البريطانيه الان في خبر عاجل لا
تنصح مواطنيها في السودان بالبقاء في
المنازل ماذا عن الاوراق السياسيه التي
ربما حتى يستطيع الدعم السريع تحريكها
ربما اقصد حتى
الام حتى الامس كانت متاحه والاحوال هادئه
ومبشره بتدخل الوسطاء من الحركات
تدخل
على حده برهان
وحمله ويعني بشروا كل الشعب السوداني بان
الحمد لله العزمه في طريقه وحتى في مطار
مرضي الاحوال
فتحت لكن ما حدث اليوم هو المسلم الذي لا
يعرفها احد التوصل التدخل هؤلاء الوسطاء
مهم حتى الذين بالامس بمشاركوا وفشل مجود
ومليون تدخلهم ضروري وهام ده كمستوى محلي
المستوى الاممي
الثلاثيه والمستوى الدولي بالرباعيه برضه
كلها مستويات مهمه ولا تاثير لها ضغوط
يعني الاتصالات لتلفونات
تدخل بين الطرفين لوقف هذا القتال ووقف
نزيف الدم داخل السودان كله دكتور جلال هل
توافق يعني من يقول بان ما حدث اليوم هو
تنفيس عن حاله الاحتقان التي وصل اليها
الطرفان البرهان وحميدتي خلال الفتره
الماضيه ابدا ابدا انا احسب انه ما حدث
اليوم يعني هو عمل مدبر يعني قصد به اخلاق
الخلق هذه الجمعه الكبيره لانه يعني قبل
ايام كانت لدينا مشكله كبيره جدا وكان
يمكن ان تنفجر مثلا لكن الحمد لله لم
تنفجر كل النفوس
فقط تسويه الامور وهذا الامور الى الاصابه
كانت في نقطه متعلقه وهي
التحذيرات القوات المسلحه اللي هي قوات
الدعم السريع الموجوده
بالعوده من حيث عدد الى حيث اتت لانه
هناك ويبدو انه الدعم السريع لن ينص فمن
هنا تعقد الموقف وزاد الشحن اما ماذا حدث
اليوم لا يمكن انت تقول انه عمل مدبر عمل
مدبر من قبل من
لا نعرفه من الذي بدل المعرفه في هذه
المعرفه لابد ان يظهر الحديث
دكتور جلال هذه الاعمده التي نشاهدها على
على الشاشه اعمده الدخان من الخرطوم لا
اعلم حقيقه باي المباني ربما هي في محيط
في محيط القصر
نعم اذا ايضا تجمع المهنيين السودانيين
نحمل الجيش والدعم السريع اي خسائر عن
الاشتباكات وسط المدنيين هذا موقف
للمهنيين السودانيين طيب هذا العمل المدبر
لمصلحه من قد يصب باعتقادك دكتور جلال لا
لا الان
يمكن ان نصل الى حكم الان وضع الاحكام
والادانات لا يمكن ان يتم الان قبل
استبانه الرؤيه وقبل التعريف من الذي بدا
وبعد ذلك اثبات انه هو الفاعل الاصلي
وعنده المصلحه بعد تتضح هي مسالته الان
هنالك قتال منتشر من طرفين بهذا يدعي انه
لم يبدا وهذا يدعي انه فلان اعتدى عليه لا
نعرف من الذي بدا الطرق تتضح
فيها كذا قتال قتال شوارع سواء للجيش او
حتى للدعم العسكري الجيش السوداني كثيره
وقادر على القتال
مشاريع عنده قواته وخفيفه لكن
ليش تاريخ
ه
الجيش السوداني عمره 100 عام من التدريب
والتاهيل والتقويه وكده يعني عنده
امكانيات ليس ولكن ايضا قوات الدعم السريع
لديها ربما خفت الحركه وهذه الاشتباكات في
في محيط متقارب يعني الحركه نعم هي لديها
خفه الحركه هذا يعني يقول له في بدايه
حديثنا لكن هي باي حال من الاحوال الجيش
قوته كبيره والجيش خبرته كبيره
وهو الان يعني يتعامل في حدود مشكلته مع
الدعم الدعم السريعون لا نحمل اي طرف
السريع الجيش لا نحمل مسؤوليه لماذا انفجر
لكن ننتظر والحكم من خلال نهايه اليوم
تظهر كل النتائج في كل القنوات طيب هذه
الصور الخاصه بالعربيه تظهر تصاعد اعمده
الدخان نتيجه للاشتباكات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع كما اشرنا
بالاسلحه الخفيفه والاسلحه الثقيله ايضا
كما اشار ضيوفي الى ان
القوات القوات الطرفين متداخله في بعض
الاماكن هي قريبه جدا من بعضها البعض هذه
الاشتباكات قريبه الجيش السوداني
استخدم في مرحله متقدمه الغطاء الجوي
للطيران الحربي الذي شوهد وهو يحلق في
سماء الخرطوم ربما يعطيه
وفقه بعض
المحللين
اليد الطوله في حسم هذه المعركه لكن الى
الان هذه المعركه
والاشتباكات لم تحسم دكتور جلال يعني انت
تقول بنهايه اليوم قد تتضح الصوره هل نقول
بانه لم تستمر للابد لابد ان تصل الى
نهايته لكن البعض قد يتخوف من انها تستمر
الى ولايات اخرى
هي اصلا موجوده الان في ولايات اخرى
موجوده في ولايه الشماليه وحدثك الان انه
هنالك انباء عن جزء من الحراك في شمال
كردفان هكذا لكن
لابد ان تكون في نهايه سواء بالتدخل السني
بوقف النار بعلمهم يعني لا يمكن ان تسامير
من ذلك لانه استمرت
الدخان ما زال القتال المستمر ولكن في
النهايه ان شاء الله حتى نهايه باذن الله
تعالى ونسال الله ان يخرجنا من هذه
اللهم امين خاصه يعني لكن لكن واقع الامر
هل يستطيع كل من الطرفين ربما تحمل هذا
الوضع
وبضغط حتى على الشارع السوداني او بضغط من
الشارع السوداني على الطرفين
واربع سنوات ينادي بالحكم المدني يطلع في
موضوع
في اواخر شهر رمضان ويسال الله ان يلطف
ويخرج يعني يخ
رجوا فيه لكن الان يعني اليوم هو نفس
الشارع السوداني مصدوم مما يرى امامه ومش
مصدوم يعني يضطر للبغاء في بيوت الناس
وانت تعلم انه الباقي له اربع ولا خمسه
ايام كله الان الى منازلهم حتى ينجلي
الموظف السوداني الان يسال الله ان تنتهي
هذه المؤسسه لاسرع ما يكونوا تنطلق
الجيش السوداني يعلن اصابه القائد
الميداني لقوات الدعم السريع في الخرطوم
هذا ايضا نحن نقول بان هناك انباء وبيانات
متبادله بين الطرفين
الطرف يكذب الطرف الاخر
بما يدور حقيقه المشهد والصوره كما هي
اعمده الدخان التي تتصاعد في هذه الكاميرا
الخاصه
بالعربيه ايضا الوضع ليس واضحا جدا سواء
في الخرطوم او حتى في مروي او كما يقول
ضيف الدكتور جلال في شمال كوردو فان
الانباء تشير الى ربما ايضا اشتباكات بين
الطرفين هناك اليوم من من الممكن ان يكون
طرفا مقبولا هل هي اتركا هل هي اللجنه
الرباعيه الدكتور جلال من يمكن ان يتدخل
ليحسم
كل هذه الاطراف الان مقبوله ومطلوبه وليس
مقبوله فقط انما مطلوبه ومقبوله قبولا
واسعا لانها شاركت في كل المفاوضات في
تطور السياسي السياسي السودان منذ عام
2019 الرباعيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي الايجاد الاتحاد
الافريقي
الممثل الامم المتحده
فضلا عن اللاعبين السياسيين الموجودين
داخل السودان سواء كانوا من مجموعه قوى
الحريه والتغيير الايطالي
تهمه الوطن باكمله تهدد لدقائق لابد من
مشاركتهم جميعا في الحراك لاجل نزع الفتيل
الازمه ووقف نزيف الدم هي ذات ذات يعني
ذات الاطراف التي كانت تدخل في حوار مع
الطرفين خلال الايام الماضيه لكن يعني كان
هناك تطمينات لها بان الوضع لن يتطور
لا الوضع اليوم بيختلف عن الوضع بالامس
وما حدث
اليوم هناك لا يمنع كل جهود ان تستمر يعني
لا نتوقف لانه كنا بلامسه تفائل واليوم
حدث ما لا
استمر في هذه المحاولات الى ان نصل الى
نتيجه للعدم بيحصل نتائج غير حميده طيب هل
دمج الدعم العسكري نتحدث عن عن يعني الجسد
العسكري اليوم دعم
ربما الدعم السريع في داخل دمج دمج مع
الجيش والقوات المسلحه باطار اخر الا يفقد
القوه
لهذا الطرف لحساب الطرف الاخر في المعادله
السياسيه والعسكريه السودانيه دكتور جلال
لا هو اصلا لن تكون هنالك قوتين بعد الدم
يعني الغرض من الدرج هو انشاء جيش وطني
واحد احترافي مؤهل وبالتالي يعني ينتهي
عمليه اللوز باضافه كل قوات
ه قوات المسلحه الى اي مدام من الممكن ان
يتنازل الاطراف
هذه الحلقه اول دوله في العالم تضم قوات
كان المسانده لها المسلحه
معلومه ومرتبه يعني ما بتحتاج
لكن طبعا في الفتره الاخيره ظهرت هذه
التعقيدات في خلال هذه الورشه الاصلاح
الامني الاخيره
ظهر يعني كان هنالك بعض التباينات في
الرؤى يعني لابد ان يعمل كذا ويعمل كذا
والزمن والرئاسه وما الى ذلك لكن فنيه
تركت للفنين قبل ان يصل الفنيين الى نتيجه
ظهر هذا الاسكان الجديد ودي مساله يعني
لا اختار حول
معروفه والقوانين والقواعد المعروفه لا
تحتاج لكبير عنها طيب الخارجيه السودانيه
المصريه قبل قليل طلبه كل الاطراف بضبط
النفس والان حزب الامه القومي السوداني
يدعو لتكوين لجنه مشتركه من الجيش والدعم
السريع للاتفاق على تهدئه بين الطرفين
نحددكم عن هذه الصور التي تردنا الان
لحريق لبرج في مقره قياده الدعم السريع
يذكر بعد قصفه من قوات الجيش السوداني
الجيش السوداني الذي استخدم
السلاح سلاح الجو في هذه والذي كان يحلق
في سماء العاصمه خرطوم اذا هذه صور
متداوله لاحراق مقر الدعم السريع واحتراق
مقر الدعم السريع داخل قياده الجيش في
الخرطوم
طيب كان هناك حديث الدكتور جلال عن وساطات
ملء ربما الذي يرضي الدعم السريع ان يكون
ذو كيان خاصا كما كان بوضع البشير ام
بالوضع
الحالي له مستقبلا كيف يمكن ان يكون ضمن
القوات المسلحه
ما هو الاطار
بهذه نقطه تم تجاوزها من خلال توقيع
الاطاري الذي ينص بصراحه ووضوح على انشاء
جيش وطني واحد لكل الشعب السوداني
فبالتالي لا مجال هنالك للجيوش اخرى الدج
ال السريع والي جيوش الحركات المسلحه التي
يخططها التي ينتظر ان تتوقع فيما بعد
كعبور برحمه
منهم هذا الجيش الواحد يعني في داخل
القوات المسلحه الموجوده
تم تجاوزها ولا مجال لوجود جيوش متعدده
هذا هو الاتفاق المنصوب عليه في الاتفاق
الايطالي ومطلوبات الدوله الحكومه المدنيه
الانتقال الديمقراطي وهكذا
شكرا
اذا شكرا دكتور جلالته وراء الخبير الامني
والاستراتيجيه الفريق الدكتور جلال شكرا
جزيلا لك كنت معنا من الخرطوم نعود
لشبكه مراسلينا وهذه المره مع مراسلنا
سالم الهاشمي من الخرطوم سالم اخر تفاصيل
المشهد لديك في الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
سالم يبدو ان الصوت ربما
اذا كان من تفضل تفضل الان تفضل تفضل
نعم الان يعم هدوء قليلا منذ تقريبا 20
دقيقه حتى الان توقفت
اطلاق الناريه وكذلك
اطلاق
المدفعيات هل انحسرت رقعه الاشتباكات بين
الطرفين اماكنها
[موسيقى]
ربما يفهم هذا الانحشار من خلال توقف غير
الناريه او
خمسه
الدخان منتشره بكثافه مناطق مختلفه من
المكان الذي انا اتواجد فيه الان في منطقه
بحري
وصله اللهب في في مناطق مختلفه جدا في كل
الاتجاهات ابرزها في الاتجاه الذي فيه جسر
شنبات الرابط بينهم درمان وبين البحري
وكذلك في الجهه الجنوبيه كذلك المتعلقه
بمركز الخرطوم والمنطقه منطقه كوبرا التي
فيها مقر من مقر الدعم السريع الارض
طيب ماذا عن صحه الانباء بسيطره الدعم
السريع وايضا بيان الجيش حول السيطره على
المقر مقر مقر القياده
والقصر الرئاسي تحديدا
نعم نعم متداوله حول هذا الموضوع بشكل
كبير
لكن هناك انباء ايضا كان في هذا الامر
فلا توجد اخبار دقيقه حول هذا الموضوع حتى
هذه اللحظه لكن اعلنت الجهات لها علاقه
بقوات الدعم السريع او اكدت لنا عن حصيه
الرد على القياده العامه وانها تسيطر على
مطار الخرطوم تسيطر على مطار الابيض تسيطر
على مدار مروي هذا ما اكدته ايضا للتوضيح
هناك فيديو متداول ضابط مسار
القوات المسلحه السودانيه والجيش السوداني
اعلن سلخه من قوات الدعم السريع وانهى
امتدابه وهو في هذا الفيديو يدعو ايضا الى
الى كل الضباط الذين انكذبوا من القوات
المسلحه الى الانسلاخ بين القوات الدعم
السريع هذا عرصا على بيان الجيش الذي ذكر
ان هذه الاموات الدعم الصحيحيه قوه
لها بالعقد شكرا جزيلا سالم الهاشمي مراسل
العربيه من الخرطوم شكرا جزيلا لك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات